In a further distance course you have to,
yeah,
but it also makes you susceptible for counters in a way like,
like when,
when Connor was fighting Floyd,
my biggest concern for Connor was not speed or counterpunching.
It was the distance that you're going to be able to counter.
And when,
when Connor caught Floyd a cough Floyd a couple times in the beginning,
I think one was a left upper cut he called flood.
That was shocking to me because I was surprised that he had boxing counter
punching speed.
The distance is half.
Yeah.
Compared to a kick sport.
I would say if we're standing what,
two,
three feet away from each other in kickboxing,
it's one and a half unboxing.
So to cut that distance in half and still have the counterpunching ability was
impressive.
Yeah.
I mean,
well he's done a lot of
lower level boxing and the gym,
stuff like that is when you get up to that level,
it's a different fucking gay Floyd Mayweather is on a completely different
planet than anybody else.
He's the greatest of all time.
Yeah,
that's what I'm meaning like I think he's better at boxing.
Then Stephen Hawking is astrophysics.
You might be right.
Look,
he's 50 and now the con it does count even though it probably shouldn't.
Right.
I mean it was a real boxing match,
but it was a guy that had zero professional boxing matches.
Uh,
but he did get tagged Connor.
Ken Punch.
He's a good fighter.
He's a very good mixed martial arts fighter.
But the thing about Floyd is that Floyd is the best at not getting hit.
No one's better.
So I've been tagged,
really tagged like three times,
four times in his whole career.
I can name five times.
Yeah.
It should be Shane Mosley,
my Donna the end of the fourth round.
Yup.
Um,
the other ones are early.
I'm Judah.
Right Hook.
I actually talked to him.
Sam shooter was a wicked man.
It was great.
His Dad was a kickbox.
That's right.
He came from that.
What does the name something something,
dude,
I forget his name,
but all guys.
You all did.
You all do it?
Yeah.
And then,
uh,
to Marcus Chop Chop quarterly.
Oh,
that's right.
I forgot them.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
It was.
Um,
yeah,
my,
my pops was like a massive box and Fannie,
we still go to Ollie's a,
he was a journalist back in the day,
used to cover like Ali and his fight something.
That's why I kind of came up,
you know,
generationally watching boxing.
So that's awesome.
Yeah Dude,
it was like,
I mean some of the best moments,
you know what Floyd has going for him,
that the best Jujitsu guys have going for him is that he's not physically
powerful.
Like the best Jujitsu guys are smaller people,
right?
Because the smaller people learn how to use leverage and technique and the camp
muscle things.
Whereas if you look at 250 pound gorilla,
here's some good old football player dude.
And you're like,
man,
I don't want to words fuck Jujitsu.
Like you don't ever have to be on your back.
Right.
You know,
like I was talking to [inaudible] about that shops thinking about doing jujitsu
again cause I was telling him,
I got back into it recently,
I'm really enjoying it and he's like,
ah,
I don't know.
I go,
just roll off your back man.
Tell him to be a big guy with a guard.
No big guys have gone.
It's so rare,
right?
Because big guys just get little guys on the ground and they have a nasty top
game,
but then when they find themselves on their back,
a lot of them are turtles.
Right?
Ooh.
They don't know what to do.
Yeah.
It's a technique thing.
A little guy has to learn perfect precision technique because they don't have
that exercise or power point guard.
The NBA,
Floyd has weekends cans.
He's broken his hands many times.
Yeah.
And even though he's capable of knocking guys out,
it's with precision.
All these,
he's going to knock you out like a John the beast Mugabi would or a Francis and
Ghana would,
or a fucking a real power punch or Joe Smith.
There's guys who just fucking get you to the cage or in the in against the ropes
and just smash.
Yeah.
Uncanny.
Some of these guys,
it's just raw power and it's,
Yep.
He,
Floyd is all precision and he's all like,
one of the most fun things for me is,
is watching Floyd in the first round and watching him take away your life.
Like I like to see him take away a fighter's confidence,
right?
Like he knew that Moseley was going to get off with the jab,
or at least he knew,
mostly thought that he was going to get off with the jab.
And there's a moment,
even in the first round,
I know he gets tagged with that overhand right,
but there's a moment where Mosley,
Mosley pops the Left Jab and Floyd sees it steps back slightly and then come
straight over at the right.
And that moment you could see Shane know that there's nothing he can do because
Floyd has time the Jab and countered it directly.
So now your job is done now blocked off one of your arms.
I've literally just cut it off.
Now you got to open up with the right.
You're not gonna do anything to me.
Just straight right.
I mean,
I got the Philly shell,
it's over.
It's like seeing him take pieces away from a fighter.
It's,
I just,
I love fucking,
yeah
man.
Well he learns how to,
I'm the biggest boy,
Paul Young age too.
And His dad was a wizard.
His Dad when he was young,
fought sugar ray Leonard and of course good fight when sugar ray was in his
prime.
Good pedigree men comes from good pedigree.
They know how to do it.
A smart fighter schools.
Roger Mayweather,
Black Mamba was his brother was a motherfucker man.
I used to love watching his brother fight pack and the,
or is a,
is a uncle rather.
I used to love watches,
uncle fight.
He would fight on like ABC,
like whatever television shows were having boxing on television during the day.
Maybe it was ABC,
I don't remember.
But yeah,
like that family,
he grew up boxing and he also got to see the things that people do wrong,
you know?
And here's another thing that Floyd has going for him.
Conditioning unfathomed he's always in tremendous shape.
Always just always in shape.
I think it's a hustle.
When you see a meeting,
the mcdonalds and shit,
nothing.
I hundred percent regularly,
100% you can eat that shit.
It's just carbohydrates.
It's just bullshit.
The thing about that,
like either the eating sugar or uh,
like he'll drink a soda after a workout.
He's working out for two and a half hours so you can take some sugar dude.
Not only can you take some shade,
there is an argument that that kind of sugar is not bad for you after you have a
brutal workout.
Dude,
when I was,
we did this sober October challenge.
Yeah.
Showing a three man,
dude already looked phenomenal fucking free.
So I'm in New York.
I was like,
dude,
you had add.
He was going to be my biggest competition too cause he hired in his face.
Like his head is just exhausted.
Yeah.
He's like,
yeah,
so door to this bullshit,
but his body was fucking shredded.
Shredded.
What does this head Johnson,
he always eats McDonald's and he's doing it.
Yeah.
While he's working out right here.
Yeah,
dude,
you can do that.
It's all in how much you exercise now that's not,
please go chat.
Obviously he's eating healthy food on top of that,
but if he feels like fucking off and getting a big Mac,
he could do that.
And there's no,
no performance benefit.
Nope.
No penalty.